TODAY.
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND THE FIRST
LADY WILL TRAVEL TO KENTUCKY ON
MONDAY TO SEE FIRSTHAND THE
DAMAGE DONE BY THAT DEADLY
FLOODING.
>>> 37 PEOPLE ARE DEAD, BUT THAT
NUMBER COULD RISE AS OFFICIALS
CONTINUE SEARCHING FOR THE
MISSING.
CNN'S DIANNE GALLAGHER FILED
THIS REPORT FROM EASTERN
KENTUCKY WHERE ENTIRE TOWNS HAVE
NOTHING LEFT.
PEOPLE ARE STILL WITHOUT POWER,
AND EVERYTHING IS BURIED IN A
FOOT OF MUD.
>> WE'RE NOT, WE'RE NOT VICTIMS
HERE.
WE'RE SURVIVORS.
>> Reporter: AS THE PEOPLE OF
EASTERN KENTUCKY DIG OUT OF THE
MUD, THEY'RE PRAYING FOR A
MIRACLE IN THE FORM OF
DONATIONS, GOOD WILL, AND DRY
WEATHER.
VOLUNTEERS LINED UP AT THE APPLE
SHOP IN WHITESBURG TO SHORT AND
ATTEMPT TO SALVAGE HUNDREDS OF
SOAKED BUT PRICELESS PIECES OF
APPALACHIAN HISTORY.
JUST ACROSS THE RIVER, ANOTHER
PIECE OF APPALACHIAN CULTURE
CAKED IN MUD AFTER A FLOOD
RIPPED THROUGH THIS DOWNTOWN
DISTILLERY.
>> FIRST YOU'RE HEART BROEC AND
THEN YOU TRY TO GET IT FIXED
BACK AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
>> Reporter: COMMUNITY
TOUCHSTONES DESTROYED.
SCHOOLS, PHARMACIES, FIRE
DEPARTMENTS, AND GROCERY STORES.
NOTHING SPARED IN THESE TINY
TOWNS.
>> YOU THINK OF IT AS A STORE,
BUT IT'S ACTUALLY A GATHERING
PLACE FOR EVAN.
>> Reporter: WHILE THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT WAS DOING BOAT
RESCUES, THEIR BOAT FLOODED,
FIRE TRUCK SWEPT AWAY.
THE MAJORITY OF THE DEATHS
HAPPENED IN KNOT COUNTY
INCLUDING FOUR CHILDREN.
FOR THOSE WHO SURVIVED THE
FLOOD, SURVIVING THE AFTERMATH
BRINGS NEW CHALLENGES, WHICH FOR
MANY BECOMES MORE DIFFICULT BY
THE DAY.
>> THERE'S NOTHING LEFT.
EVERYTHING'S DESTROYED.
>> Reporter: THE RURAL NATURE OF
THE REGION COUPLED WITH THE
WATER CRUSHING ROADS AND BRIDGES
MADE RESCUE AND RESOURCES
DIFFICULT TO COME BY WITH THE
NATIONAL GUARD COMING IN BY AIR
AND NEIGHBORS BY ATV, SURVIVORS
HELPING SURVIVORS IN PLACES LIKE
WOLF COLE AND FLEMING NEON WHERE
EVERY HOME AND BUSINESS WAS
AFFECTED, LEAVING PEOPLE
STRANDED, FORCING THEM TO LIFT
THEMSELVES OUT OF THE MUD, NOT
GETTING OUTSIDE HELP FOR DAYS.
>> YOU CAN'T HELP BUT CRY, YOU
CAN'T HELP BUT CRY, BUT IT'S
GOING TO BE OKAY.
IT'S GOING TO BE OKAY.
WE'LL BE BACK.
>> Reporter: SURVIVORS LIKE THE
FIRE CHIEF WHO HUNG ONTO THE TOP
OF THE TANKER FOR 15 HOURS WHERE
THE FLOODWATERS ROLLED AROUND.
TO REALLY RECOVER, THEY'LL NEED
MORE THAN REPAIRS.
>> I KIND OF WONDERED ABOUT
THINGS, HOW TO GO FORWARD, BUT,
YOU KNOW, I'VE GOT TO FIX MYSELF
FIRST.
>> Reporter: MOST WHO ESCAPED
WITH THEIR LIVES HAD LITTLEST
LEFT BEHIND WHEN THE WATER
RECEDED.
>> SEE THE WINDOW?
THAT'S HOW DEEP THE WATER WAS.
>> Reporter: GARY CLICK SAID
MOST OF HIS POSSESSIONS WERE
RUINED.
HE DIDN'T HAVE FLOOD INSURANCE
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T LIVE IN A
FLOODPLAIN.
>> I NEVER SAW WATER LIKE THAT.
>> Reporter: LARRY LIVED BY
TROUBLESOME CREEK FOR MOST OF
HIS LIFE, BUT HE'S NOT SURE IF
HIS COMMUNITY EVER INDEPENDENT
AND RESILIENT CAN EVER BE THE
SAME.
>> THIS IS REALLY THE ONTARIO
THIS LITTLE COMMUNITY.
>> Reporter: ADMITTING HE'LL
NEVER BE ABLE TO SHAKE THE FEAR
OF ANOTHER FLOOD.
>> I BELIEVE WE'RE SEEING THE
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE RIGHT
HERE.
GIVEN TIME -- IF WE DON'T TURN
IT AROUND, IT'S GOING TO GET
WORSE.
PEOPLE ARE GOI